[Music]
[Music]
the gardener lecture given by the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics at MIT
Lester Gardner was a friend of the
department was interested throughout his
career in aeronautical engineering and
was instrumental in founding in creating
the hunter Kerr professorship he was
mostly a publicist of the field of
aerospace engineering as it's now called
and was the published publisher for more
than 10 years of aviation and
aeronautical engineering and was quite a
noted contributor in his own right to
aeronautical engineering in the middle
of the century today for only the second
time in the history of the lecture we
have two lecturers who will jointly in
in a somewhat coordinated fashion give
the lecture this past week was the tenth
anniversary of the flight of the
Daedalus airplane human powered airplane
from Crete to Santorini perhaps
recreating the mythical flight of
Daedalus are going to talk about the
myth Jon you are I won't I won't take
any more of Jon's
ammunition and we thought it was an
appropriate time to to commemorate the
entire history of human powered flight
and asked two of the principals to come
and be with us today to share their
their view of this history from the
insider's view I can recall as I
literally as a young man that we had at
MIT a series of I believe it was three
symposia on low speed and motorless
flight in the late 60s and early 70s
largely organized by the late Jim Nash
Weber and brought together at that time
some of the leading figures
and builders of human powered airplanes
up to that point and my recollection of
them was the last of them was in about
1974 does anyone remember if that's 76
and that was still before any of the
Kramer prizes had actually been won if
my recollection serves me is that right
yeah so we decided to to make this in
some sense as a joint event that there
was today are organized by mark Drella
and Carolyn falkowski the technical
symposium on low speed and motorless
flight two to bring together the some of
the the ongoing technical efforts in
that area and then followed by the the
lecture this afternoon well let me
introduce very briefly our two lectures
there interestingly both founders and
and chairman or of various small to
medium-size flight vehicle companies I
guess you would say it Paul MacCready is
a figure who needs little introduction
in the world of modern aerospace
engineering he's the founder and
chairman of aero environment
incorporated a company that builds a
specialized aircraft with a particular
emphasis on advanced electric power
systems he's a member of the National
Academy and the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and as you know and
probably and will hear more about is the
the father of the gossamer family of
lightweight human-powered vehicles John
Langford is the founder president and
chairman of Aurora flight sciences a
company which specialises in flight
vehicles specialized to the
high-altitude environment and including
the Perseus proof-of-concept vehicle he
was the program manager for the Daedalus
project and the sparkplug for several of
the other previous human powered expert
of the airplanes at MIT
and in the interim between two of those
left MIT where he received his degrees
to go off and work on the F what became
the f-117 stealth fighter at Lockheed
Martin or at that time the Lockheed
corporation so without further time I
delay I'll introduce Paul MacCready who
as I understand it will speak first
thank you and good afternoon Friends of
airplanes human powered airplanes
challenges and fun this is a field
that's been going on for a long time
there's been a huge amount written about
it and in the short time we have this
afternoon there's no possible way of
going over this huge history so one is
referenced to a lot of books that exist
I've written up a version of my talk
version that doesn't have much in the
way of illustrations I'm going to show
lots of slides and videos here so it'll
be very different but the written
version does have a list of a lot of the
publications that you can read that
really give all the details on the facts
of what happened in this field of how
the field began and vents that have
taken place up till fairly recently also
I will show towards the end a video
doing more with much less that shows
gossamer Condor gossamer albatross very
briefly which you'll be hearing a lot
about in the talk but also shows some of
the things to which those have led
fitting into a theme of the doing more
with much less and we give copies of
that video to anybody who wants them but
I only have a couple of loose ones here
but if any of you will sign your name
over there I'll put a card and one of
the little bolts on the far side of that
table
apparently mit has some way of magically
seeing to it that you will receive one
which because we'll just send them a
bunch so I wanted to not duplicate
what's in the
written literature but try and look a
little broader perspectives and the
broadest perspective the start way back
looking at what flight has meant to
creatures on earth several hundred
million years ago became obvious in
evolutionary survival challenges that
the air was a wonderful Avenue to get up
into away from the things that would eat
you and instead of having to crawl over
slimy things on the ground and falling
rocks and so on there is a nice pure air
to let you escape things travel long
distances look for prey etc and there's
such value in getting up into this added
dimension in spite of all the
difficulties associated with it where
you have to have wings and need like
wing loadings and you're fragile and you
have to have a good bit of energy and a
lot of specialization but the features
are such that I think something like
three-quarters of insects fly now and
then obviously other natural fliers
birds and bats and pterosaurs were great
success stories and some of them still
are to go through this very quickly I
want to start with the first slide which
shows the four arms
one human three belonging to other
vertebrate creatures and the three top
ones fly and because this ecological
niche of flight requires with things
that grow from little creatures and DNA
requires you something they're flapping
their arms and the slide shows that all
of them have including humans have the
same basic arm structure though they
started in the flight mode
a bit different times so they
accomplished it different ways but if
you follow all four of these back far
enough you come to certainly a common
ancestor for the top pterosaurs is very
simple and it's like almost like a big
hang glider and the that the outer half
of the wing spar is just the little
finger that extended way out and birds
do it differently bats use their fingers
as the control surfaces there's a lot of
different insects some old dragonflies I
think we're about two and a half foot
wingspan back in the old days and even
now they are wonderful successes
nature's helicopters birds are similar
hummingbirds are similar nature's
helicopters and they're the hummingbird
looks very similar to hawk moth which
occupies the same flight niche they look
the same but one's an insect one's a
bird the the Flyers that were really in
awe of are they some of the more
efficient birds here's an albatross just
magnificent for going out over long
distances over the ocean and you'll
notice a very high wingspan looks almost
like a sail plane and essentially no
tail that can whip out a tail for some
type maneuvers but most of the time it
does not use one same is true the
frigate bird which soars very very
gentle up currents and convection over
oceans because it's using these weak
thermals that are about a metre a second
it ends up as a superb low speed so are
sinking speed the albatross using
dynamic soaring is more like a sort of a
bullet with wings goes a lot faster each
one fitting their niche and then when
you get over land there are many other
kinds of soaring creatures and you start
seeing ones that are very good at the
low speed flight maneuverability all
those feathers doing interesting and we
are beginning to learn very efficient
things in order to make flight work very
well and we just had a talk today on the
way wings
should join the body and turns out on
the that were resulted that resulted
from a lot of advanced theory and it
turns out they look just like the
vultures that have been around for 100
million years so we're learning that we
we now can see bugs birds and bats fly
but we can't see the pterodactyls fly
because they went extinct when the
dinosaurs went extinct 65 million years
ago as they started they the pterosaurs
they were REM fur encodes with tails
like you see here actually rather small
creatures more spiral like than the
awesome size that you see and then as
they got larger as time went on the
larger the larger ones began having no
tails it turned out an ounce of brains
used in active control seemed to be much
better than adding an extra pound of
tail on the creature so modern ones just
flew like ordinary creatures and this is
the static display model of the largest
creature that ever flew the qn--
pterodactyl of which we made a flying
model that to be in a movie called on
the wing showing the evolution of
natural flight evolution of
technological flight and there were no
pterodactyls around to take pictures of
so we made a replica only an 18-foot one
rather than thirty six foot one because
we only were able to get up through the
temperamental overweight adolescents
eyes by the time the project was done
but it worked and in the flights it
crashed often but never when the IMAX
cameras were pointed at it somehow it
knew what its mission was but to have
this thing fly is just amazing that has
no tail trying to keep it pointing
forwards like trying to shoot an era
with feathered end forward and makes you
appreciate nature is so wonderful on
active control and those other birds
that I showed you aren't using the tail
there very often it uses active control
humans are edging toward that but most
of our planes
have regular tails I've got a video that
will show this flying if you start with
number one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Nature has a lot of different ways of
having flying things showing you the for
real Flyers but then seeds are made so
they have a pretty good aerodynamics
pollen is distributed through the air
spiders on spider webs can be
transported hundreds of miles and there
are many different kinds of flight and
there flying fish and many of you won't
believe it but they're actually flying
squid and they fly in groups and fly
very beautifully not very far all this
is to emphasize that all energy of
creatures on earth really comes from Sun
with a few exceptions and with different
time constants so solar power up here
you get instantly fossil fuel with
stored energy of sunlight maybe for many
millions of years ago up here using wind
and heat to make thermals and airplanes
fly but also there's food for muscles
which is the energy that creatures use
to get around and so Hawk we'll start
with this energy and then we use a lot
that comes from wind and the heating of
the ground making thermals so I've kind
of shown a spectrum of flying things
that go from practically no weight up to
that giant pterosaur and the pterosaur
probably weighed their pterodactyl Keela
and probably weighed 180 pounds at about
a thirty six foot wingspan was the only
one of that species the large one found
and I doubt that one found the biggest
so and you look at some scaling laws and
there's no reason why they couldn't have
had one say forty foot inside feet in
size and there are some giant version
of that hawk or that vulture that I
showed that probably got up to 180
pounds and flew about six million years
ago these begin edging towards people
type weight and that that giant vulture
was probably around 20 foot wingspan
getting up towards span of that involves
real airplanes so there got to be at the
beginning of this century some interest
in human powered flight a lot more
interest at the very beginning because
people didn't know about engines
but once engines began interest in human
power flight sort of evaporated but an
early prize was to see how far you could
go just using the kinetic energy of your
momentum as you got a bicycle and
significant prize and it helped
competitions like this do help a field
move along there's another prize put up
in the middle of the 30s this is one of
the planes that attempted to do it and
they're really very great pioneering
airplanes person in there pedaling
couldn't quite climb but could greatly
extend the glide but I think had been
sort of sandbagged with the requirement
of the government leaving Italy that
this had to meet all the the strength
requirements of regular commercial
aircraft even though it would never fly
higher than ten feet and that rather
limited it was a great pioneering effort
and then a big moment in this field
there had been a man powered aircraft
group associated with Royal Aeronautical
Society for a while
Henry Kramer was a friend of some of
those people and after selling a
division of one of his companies he had
a party to celebrate and asked one of
these people how is that human powered
airplane stuff going and his friend
replied wasn't going anyplace they're
just sitting around talking to each
other it was going to take something
like a prize to make it go to get that
field going and Kramer who was starting
on his third martini said I'll put up a
prize and that was the deep insight that
went into what I think is one of the
you'll find from the consequence one of
the most creative action activities in
the 20th century and and does get you to
think about the importance of ethanol as
an energy producer or Liberator
anyhow Kramer is short fellow right
there and right after his prize came out
teams in England began focusing their
attention are really getting stuff out
I'm not sure which plane this is it
might be the puffins but they built
several large span quite sophisticated
though sophisticated one of the
definitions in dictionary is
unnecessarily complicated you wonder why
so many ribs and so on well it's easy to
be judgmental after long after the fact
this was a great pioneering activity at
the time illustrates some of the
difficulties but illustrates some of the
successes and they were able to actually
get the plane like this off into the air
under the high power that a pilot puts
out for and put out for a very short
period of time but it couldn't turn and
when it crashed would be six months or
so before they'd be back flying again
because of its complexity and there's
there Gant began ignore the albatross
that followed later but there began
being various planes that no need to go
into if you really want to get the
history there are a bunch of books that
give it in delightful fashion but bunch
of groups did work on this but the
surprising thing was after the first
flush of sort of success the first few
years it turned out people weren't
getting any closer to winning that prize
which was ingeniously the rules were me
asleep as a figure eight flight around
two pylons half a mile apart required
something to be able to turn left turn
right go up high enough the beginning
the end of the flight so it couldn't be
just some exaggerated ground effect
machine it took long enough so you
couldn't get by on that anaerobic power
where a pilot can put out one and a half
horsepower for a few seconds it had to
be the aerobic continuous power where
he's down to more like third or a half a
horsepower
I had no interest in the subject at all
but I had a background that was fairly
useful to prepare me for this insanity
about the the only interest I was like
everybody in the soaring activity I was
aware of the competition and I think in
the 1974 MIT event I was back here and
actually saw movies of one of those
planes fly think might have been Jupiter
and it was very dramatic and that
imprinted itself on my mind but I had no
interest in the the whole topic but I
did have a background in model airplane
building when I was a youngster and I
would make these indoor models somebody
else's I'm not a youngster here the
thing like this away about a gram for
the model for a 1 meter wingspan and the
rubberband that powers it another gram
and they've gotten up to one hour flight
indoors with these and propeller just
slowly goes like that and it kind of
moves through the air like a fish
gliding through a an aquarium it's kind
of a art form turns out to be amazingly
analogous structurally and and stability
and control wise to the gossamer
airplane is also familiar with hang
gliders because with my sons we were
playing with these as the sport was
getting pioneered in Southern California
in the first half of the 1975 1970s and
again came to appreciate the virtues of
tubes and compression exterior wire
bracing simple sail construction well
and I was also involved in streamlining
bike activities international human
powered vehicle Association began
getting going then go as fast as you can
with no rules rules stifled by
development for a long time now just go
as fast as you can and great
developments took place and through that
I was getting very familiar with
exercise physiology championship
bicyclists exercise training techniques
and so on and then on vacation trip my
mind got away with my mind daydreaming
it's very hard to find any daydreaming
time these days with so many pressures
but the only time I've ever gotten a Big
Ideas when I've been daydreaming mind
thinks for itself decides on what it
wants to think about and it was
connecting some some things in my mind
one of which was gotten a debt because
as a good guy guaranteed somebody's note
that a bank for a hundred thousand
dollar loan to start a company which
didn't succeed he couldn't pay it back I
was stuck with a note and didn't have
the cash to do anything about it but I
assure you that was stuck in my mind
someplace even on vacation trips your
unconscious would nibble away at that I
was aware that had no interest in the
Kramer prize which I had I did know it
was up to fifty thousand pounds but once
in middle vacation going I looked the
newspaper I found the pound was worth
two dollars at that time and suddenly
this light bulb just glowed over my head
why that's the same amount as my debt
how exciting an important human powered
flight is so I began concentrating on it
very hard and tried you know I'm
aerodynamicist I should be able to
figure things out but every design I
came up with were like those people in
England that were not able to that
didn't come close to succeeding with big
teams and big complex elegant airplanes
and invited my head against that wall
for a while gave up went off did other
things I was doing some studies a bird
flight timing how long it takes for bird
to go around in a circle look at the
bank angle you can tell it's flight
speed flight radius and then I began
comparing this bird with that bird
comparing dog doing scaling laws that
relate different size and weights and
speed compare that with a hang glider
and a sail plane and this hobby thing
suddenly as often happens I talk back
about human hard flight and realized hey
it's all solved there was an easy way to
do it which is if you make something
large enough and light enough if the
weight just doesn't go up and you can
keep making a thing like a hang glider
bigger and bigger and bigger no matter
how ugly it is if it's big enough yet
you can fly it on very low power and so
immediately made a model as soon as that
vacation trip was done you see here the
test didn't
you make a very large wing I had no
knowledge of wing structure but I had
knowledge of indoor models and so on
just used logic this is the best way to
make a lightweight structure and that's
the model and about two months later we
were flying the first version of the
gossamer Condor 55 pound weight with my
hundred and five pound son flying at the
time who would fly as slowly as six
miles an hour and had a lot of problems
with it in everything that exaggerated
the problem so that you could identify
him understand them but had one great
feature which is it was quick to repair
modify alter redesign and if if it
crashed on landing you didn't grab it
properly as it slid a little sideways
because stability control was just awful
and that too broke you'd get a broom
handle and some duct tape and take the
broom handle back on you'd be flying in
five minutes that accident would have
kept those people in England not flying
for something like six months so we got
huge amount of flight experience out of
this learning all the difficulties is
just so thin fragile it seems as though
the shadow looks a little more solid
than the airplane does well we had we
began sensing the reason for some of
these problems was an apparent mass
effect that exists on all airplanes but
completely negligible the mass of air to
which you're coupled on the the plane a
regular plane is negligible compared to
the airplane here it was much much
larger than the mass of the airplane and
the person and it was affecting what was
going on Viking the controllability and
the total energy during acceleration
during turning why we couldn't turn we
use advanced computer models on
stability and control trying to get
answers about this and all the computer
models said is those flight observations
you made which is there's nothing you
could do to that wing in drag a L'Orange
dragged rotors would make any difference
just keep flying straight and maybe
sliding off on a side and that's what we
saw on that's what the computer said
yeah that's right
they didn't tell us what to do so I put
a couple of sticks together that had
gossamer Condor proportions shoved it
around in the swimming pool as you see
here here's one of the sons doing it
with your hand just feeling like the
force balance in a in a wind tunnel but
here you're working in the fluid almost
a thousand times denser than air so that
apparent mass effect is really
emphasized and within five minutes we
had the main answers what the
inarticulate computers hadn't been able
to tell us and we came up with the final
design a lot of the designing in detail
was done by friendly friends who had
lured into the project is very much a
team effort they were experienced at
build airplanes boats so on and this is
the way the drawings were done we never
had a set of plans until after the prize
was won the prize was not for drawing
plans it was for doing the flight and we
didn't have to worry about numbering
plans and storing them so on yeah we use
computers on prop design and some
airfoil and stuff like that
when it was needed when this was okay
that's what we did
and wind took care of erasing stuff when
you were done it was appropriate
technology it's not the way to design
airliners but that's what we did and a
little bit on the construction aluminum
tube if the wall was too thick you idiot
chemically milled down to the correct
thickness and looking in the wind just a
lot of pieces of tape covered mylar now
we're making it a double surface plane
and got my youngest son or middle son
Tyler another person had been doing the
main test flying but that person had to
go off to Belgium so Tyler did a bunch
of the test flying next just working on
on a gamma to build himself up the
amount of power you have to put out is
about proportional to your weight and a
young person older person can do it and
he had some flight skills and he works
cheap so we got him and with a new
version it was flying beautifully right
off the bat but still a lot of little
little problems with it and structural
and we needed to lighten its weight and
so on but it was kind of going in the
right way
we then decided we it was going okay now
we needed a real pilot Brian Allen and
here is with some of his exercise
training we were very lucky to locate
and he's a gifted pilot but also very
good on stamina willing fit into such a
project works on airplanes and we were
just so lucky but the biggest the most
important thing in this project was lots
of luck and getting him was a big part
of that now let's have the next video
rather than showing you a lot of
gossamer Condor things this video taken
from the kiosk of the national show some
of the part in led by dr. Paul MacCready
of Aero vironment incorporated the
development of the gossamer Condor a
year and was a friends and family affair
the earliest version demonstrated
featherweight slow flying aircraft
read the airspeed okay sock it to it
twisted let's get up about three feet
okay
[Music]
thirty-five
like battling left
the builders learned from both crashes
and computer programs and they made many
changes to create the final airplane
with a 96 foot wingspan and weighing
only 70 pounds six minutes and two turns
later
the only obstacle left is the 10 foot
finish Pole
[Applause]
on his prize-winning flight Brian Allen
landed with the words we did it a
tribute to the teamwork that made the
gossamer Condor fly into aviation
history this is a shot during that
flight the flight was great the pressure
was off the prize was one good bit of it
have been consumed in expenses on the
project and there's always a team I'm
sorry that the only way you'll get an
idea of the teams on all these projects
is to read the publications they were
not one person effort at all the team
was very important part ears Kramer at
the prize event in England a wonderful
forest Prince Charles gave the actual
trophy and cheque from Royal
Aeronautical Society and ended up in the
National Air and Space Museum where we
have recently last year cleaned it all
up and we didn't think it was going to
last there more than two years because
it was also baggy and floppy and taped
pulling and pulling out but now it's
kind of cleaned up and we put a
mannequin in looks just like Brian Allen
so people can see which way it goes and
the the kiosk video shows a lot of
people flying it after the prize flight
old ladies and little kids and so on to
make it make people realize this was
kind of a person next door project not
some big aerospace firm activity Kramer
came out with a new prize taking 18
years for somebody to go a mile he
thought it'd take another 18 years for
somebody go 23 miles across the English
Channel but we realized we just cloned
the gossamer Condor cut down the power
required 20% or so and selected the
right day pilot could fly much much
longer and do the job but now he was
carbon now no no new ideas in the
aerodynamics it wasn't all that
interesting a project but in the
structure carbon tubing instead of the
aluminum and
many more ribs much more accurately
contoured airfoil so on and flew
perfectly right off the bat but like our
previous ones
there were various there are some
crashes and as we assess the situation
it looked as though to get enough
testing on this get it over to England
back was going to cost a bunch of money
we were able to get the DuPont company
to spring for sponsoring the project and
letting us keep the prize money as a
carrot out in front of us and so project
charged ahead you're doing some quick
flights as we began building cleaning up
the first plane we'd put my youngest son
because the only way 80 pounds in it and
you could just push it around and
nothing would get hurt if it hit hard
and then fix it up and Brian Allen was
doing a good job
flying but he was only able to fly about
20 minutes with this particular prop and
by going to a different problem that
gene Larrabee a design and people at MIT
here helped us with or actually did the
detail design than we did the building
this optimized the prop very elegantly
for the cruise condition on the flight
and with playing Brian did a flight of
about an hour and 20 minutes landed and
felt he could have gone on forever so we
were off to England miraculously we
didn't know how to get to England but in
the middle of the night I get a phone
call very muffled have the alcohol those
airplanes at Nellis Air Force Base at
2:00 a.m. on Saturday and that was the
message and so there is a c-130 from
Royal Aeronautical Society three human
powered airplanes were all crammed
inside and all our belongings and so on
it was just another well luck a good
luck is more important than anything
Brian Allen doing a lot of training in
England and training with Joe master
Paolo in hot humid conditions with no
air blowing on and in order to get
training for what it would be like in
the plane during the flight then on the
day when the weather looked as though it
just might be okay we're on the
worn near Dover getting ready for the
flight to begin let's have the next wait
a minute before the video begins the
takeoff because of that prop was great
for crews but it was rather poor for
takeoff when you're going very slowly
and we hadn't realized how bad we had
always done it on big airports before
here we put out a little runway of
pieces of plywood the wing running
wasn't done quite right and the plane
got just off the plywood and the little
toy two-ounce wheel fell into the only
little hole in that big acre of concrete
and snapped and so there's the plane
that was our start and this is an
audience participation exercise you're
asked to see if you can figure out who
is the the DuPont representative who is
running the project but about 10 minutes
later plane started on what the most
fantastic journey most fantastic
physical stamina event that I've ever
heard of
[Music]
nam lee brian pedals on no longer
counting time his flight instruments no
longer function
his water supplies exhausted
when at last he cites the French coast
through the haze his heart sinks it is
still three miles away
[Music]
Brian each moment now has become a
victory dehydrated and suffering severe
leg cramps his judgment has begun to
waver briefly he considers crashing on
the rocky point
[Applause]
instead he fights to save the outlet
cross from the turbulence than the
clause added and nearly wrecks it a few
feet offshore
and slowly at last
okay and a bigger team but many of the
same members from the first team on this
project we never had so much pressure
and I've never been so exhausted and all
the people we were using psychic
kinetics for
telekinesis or whatever for lifting
Brian during that whole thing from boat
it was tough this shows at her apartment
we're into a lot of different things and
when these human powered airplanes began
to spawned a big list of projects that
are ongoing now and we're growing 240
people were going as fast as we can find
really qualified people and it relates
to ground things and energy things with
a lot of commonality between all these
there many too many things to describe
that the gossamer aircraft led to the
important point is that it led to just
so many things that I heartily recommend
everybody should get a hundred thousand
dollar debt to get themselves moving and
and also get some projects that don't
require a product the next year but let
you really explore the frontiers of some
technology here's the first solar flight
there 80 pounds Sun still because we
didn't have many solar cells and that
actually climbed a little bit just on
the power of solar cells this is Bionic
bat that won two of the Kramer Speed
prizes and here's a flying telephone
pole that's very hard to describe but
it's amazing what things will fly out of
El Mirage and let's well I'll go back on
this as a human power this is the last
of the human power slides there's a
human powered airplane that our sons
figured out how to do and this kid who
can walk a whole city block with his
hands in his pockets and just the up
current of the air going around his body
and over his forehead will keep that
airplane up there we have not found this
to be a
a marketable talent unfortunately and
he's just home goofing off right now
let's have the next videos it made some
big planes the but also some little
planes here you see a little thing
weighs one point eight grams zooming
around the room and under radio control
it's got a video camera in it and all
the telemetry and so on and so do you
you'll catch it on this one which is the
preferred landing technique and then on
the next go-around who had flown these
inside auditoriums like this but and now
you'll see what the airplane saw it was
very crude camera we have better ones
now color and a little higher light
level and so on but you you are there
okay next video please
the next video I I won't have time today
to show you the Birdman contest showing
you things that we did Birdman contest
in Japan they have 70 human power or
glider aircraft fly that are just
wonderful it's a wonderful training aid
it seems silly they're all destroyed
they go out from a 10-meter platform
over the water and they all land in the
water and that's the end of
doing more as much less that you get a
free copy of
[Music]
is a vital feature of a world that works
where our increasing demands are met yet
to not overwhelm the limits of the earth
some of the unusual efficient vehicles
with which arrow vironment has been
involved serve as visual metaphors for
the theme most traumatic is the unmanned
100-foot solar-powered Pathfinder here
undergoing low altitude tests in late
1993 versions are aimed at eternal
flight or at least flights for months
above 65,000 feet to carry equipment for
surveillance stratospheric monitoring
and telecommunications last summer 2007
T pound gossamer albatross was peddled
20 across the English Channel in 1979
doing the largest prize and aviation
history it demonstrates what can be done
with low power when new concepts of
efficiency are unleashed by challenges
not burdened by constraints from narrow
rules or the need for commercial
production it is a catalyst for new
perspectives that can lead to useful
insights and products such as the
Pathfinder and incidentally it was a
tribute to the human spirit
the more primitive and fragile gossamer
Condor was the first really successful
human powered airplane the final version
can be seen at the National Air and
Space Museum where it was installed
after this 1977 flight won the first
Cramer prize about this time the
International human powered vehicle
association was starting to organize
competitions for land vehicles without
the inhibiting effect of rules just go
as fast as you can the streamlined gold
rush finally exceeded 65 miles per hour
and a two-person version averaged over
50 miles an hour on a 40 mile freeway
trip later competition started to
include some less extreme practical
vehicle categories no match for our
wonderful modern cars but valuable and
suggesting that some transportation need
not involve large amounts of Steel and
oil and can be healthy in flight
pioneering for speed from human power
has resulted in some amazing water
vehicles this flying fish hydrofoil
lowers drag by flying on a submerged
wing it has been pedaled at 18 miles per
hour and can beat the best a toward
racing shows in 1987 General Motors
teamed with AeroVironment for the rapid
development of the GM Sun racer to be
entered in the world Solar Challenge to
cross Australia on energy from sunlight
it one speeding 50 percent faster than
the runner-up and averaging 42 miles per
hour on only a kilowatt of power
batteries to store the intermittent
energy from the Sun for vehicle use are
essential and obviously for non race
purposes they can be charged from the
utility grid without need for solar
cells this solar car race helped
emphasize that battery-powered cars can
make sense next the same team combined
to create the battery power to impact
demonstrator to show that car is
emitting no pollution can be part of our
transportation future
it needed adequate range and snappy
acceleration here at zooms from zero to
60 miles per hour in eight seconds now
many groups are increasing priorities on
battery powered vehicles vehicle
efficiency in general and broader
transportation issues impractical human
powered airplanes streamlined bikes and
solar powered cars now see more valuable
as some of the ideas they ignited
evolved into socially desirable vehicles
aimed at a mass market globally bikes
are widely employed for personal
mobility transport of goods and
recreation for some uses battery assist
a scaled-down version of electric car
technology makes sense you can get the
help of a virtual peddler here hidden in
the saddlebags who weighs only a few
pounds and never talks back not to turn
your bicycle into a motorcycle but to
let you do for 30 minutes what your
normal ability would let you do for only
three minutes you can extend your
commuting range with this Bionic hybrid
that will never run out of gas you can
match performance between individuals or
not be bothered by hills on a hot
afternoon a tiny airplane the a/b
pointers serves for surveillance in
effect a pair of roving eyeglasses a
cutting-edge example of wear of
miniaturization can lead if the operator
is remote from the vehicle it is
convenient to carry assemble and launch
by hand battery-powered it is silent and
rarely noticed it sends high-resolution
video pictures back to the operator with
onboard GPS it can navigate autonomously
and it is rugged enough to self land
without damage the modern sail plane is
superbly efficient some can glide as
flat as 60 feet forward for every foot
of descent they are powered only by the
energy they can extract from the
atmosphere and atmosphere nature stirs
up by solar energy humans and soaring
birds have found nature to be generous
in providing replenishable energy sale
plans have flown over 1,000 miles and
the altitude record is over 50,000 feet
the solar challenger was made to serve
as a symbol that photovoltaic cells can
produce real power and will be part of
the world's energy future in 1981 it
flew 163 miles from Paris to England
solely on the power of sunbeams and
established a basis for the Pathfinder
the message from all these vehicles is
that ideas and technology can be
harnessed to produce remarkable gains in
doing more with less gains that can help
us attain a desirable balance between
technology and nature the stakes are
high as we speed toward a challenging
future
Buckminster Fuller said it clearly there
are no passengers on Spaceship Earth
only crew we the crew can and must do
more with less much less thank you
[Applause]
John Langston takes over
thank you very much Paul and I'd like to
say thank you very much to to ed Crawley
for organizing this this is a great
opportunity and a great event to to put
two programs together here what I'd like
to do if we could bring the first slide
up and bring the lights down and the
first slide up is to is to take up where
where Paul left off in many ways in the
story of human powered flight and talk
for a few minutes about the the MIT side
of it and in particular it's the the
Daedalus project obviously that has
epitomized this but I'd like to speak as
well about the whole history of this
with an emphasis on on the role of these
these things as student teaching tools
because they have played a unique role
in the department over the last 20 years
or so this is the the famous image of
Daedalus 88 arriving at at Santorini 10
years ago just last week after about a
four-hour flight over 72 miles a hundred
and fifteen kilometers the product of a
three-year program here at MIT and
piloted by Canelo scan lopoliths and
it's our very great pleasure to have
Canelo's here today if you could stand
up for a minute Kanellis this is his
first time in the United States
this is the first time that Canelo's has
returned to MIT since he was here before
the flight training and we're delighted
to to have him and so many other members
of the Daedalus team back as I mentioned
the the project really goes back 20
years or so and many of the themes that
that that Paul was talking about a few
minutes ago play right in in here that
the the Kramer prize served as the
impetus for and the stimulus for a
number of student projects beginning
here in the early 1970s this aircraft
was one of two called the biplane
ultralight research device our bird
which were built here in the department
by two teams of several teams of
students during the early 1970s this was
what the finished configuration looked
like this was about a 60-foot span
two-person aircraft and as Paul has has
has just narrated the story of the
gossamer Condor once the once the Condor
one the the Kramer prized the first one
in 1977 for the figure-of-eight flight
interest in these in these projects
languished somewhat as Paul mentioned
there was a subsequent prize offered for
cross-channel flight there had been a
number of other activities here at MIT
the one that that that our group
particularly came out of was the model
aircraft group and the the model rocket
society which had been actually
pioneering the techniques that that Paul
showed a few minutes ago in that micro
air vehicle flying around inside which
is now a program supported by DARPA the
Defense Projects Agency in the one of
the big advances here at MIT in the late
1970s was the miniaturization of radio
control technology and its application
to these small radio control boost
gliders here flying for the US team in
the World Championships in 1978 where
Harald guppy younggren won the first
World World Championship in in this was
now
the we got involved in the in the
activity of human powered aircraft here
you can see there's guppy the world
champion on the right and professor
Drella in the in the center driven by
the the interest in in this as student
project supposing supposed to be fun and
interesting I think yeah as as Paul
alluded to though there were some very
serious aspects of this as well and and
one of the first areas that that that
the MIT group really was able to
distinguish itself in was the design and
the application of numerical methods to
to airfoils and particularly to
propellers and as G as as Paul mentioned
Jean Larabee had was influential in this
bringing the methods of Prandtl and bets
and glowered and and updating them from
for computer execution and it was really
generation of students they're working
under Jean that that coded that up and
the the propeller became the first real
visible implementation of this this is
its mark hot-wiring a piece of that
propeller these large four meter
diameter props built-in in little 66
inch long sections here and then
obviously there was interchange back and
forth all throughout this with with the
with the two teams we were able to
design the the propeller for the
gossamer albatross aircraft and and and
Paul contributed enormous ly to the
efforts here at MIT providing a lot of
tips about how these aircraft went
together particularly the lessons from
the Condor and the albatross experience
and as well as providing material all of
the year all of the skin covering the
mylar for the first chrysalis aircraft
that we built were donated by by Paul as
part of this this is the spring of 1979
guppy and and and Paul here and I think
this is in Henry Jackson's backyard
Henry is here today from from Santa
Monica this was the aircraft that
resulted from our efforts chrysalis a
large biplane 70 foot two foot wingspan
not really intended at the time to be a
serious contender for the cross-channel
prize
but as a way of getting a new generation
of MIT students into the air it was
distinguished I think by by a number of
firsts certainly at this point it had
among the highest number of flights ever
made something like 350 flights on this
airframe without a crash or serious
rebuild on it and holds at least one
record that continues to stand which is
to our knowledge the only person who's
ever flown both under their own power
and has flown in space as as J apt
another MIT graduate who who flew the
chrysalis among many others in in the
summer of 1979 their chrysalis project
was overcome of course by the albatross
which won the Cramer cross-channel prize
in June of 79 a few days after chrysalis
made its first flight which I think Paul
has has narrated fabulously for us there
and there was a subsequent series of of
Kramer competitions called the speed
prizes to make airplanes smaller and
hopefully more practical we were able to
to win first place in that competition
with an aircraft here called the monarch
which flew in the nineteen was built and
flown in 1983 and in 1984 out at out at
Hanscom field there the idea here was to
fly a sort of a metric mile flight 1,500
meters in the first one in under three
minutes I think one the the 30,000 pound
prize for that to that flight that that
was a great experience but the
combination of the chrysalis experience
the the monarch experience and the the
gossamer series left a number of us
wondering where this would lead if it
wasn't driven by the by the impetus of
these of the prizes the prizes certainly
provided a good focus point but they
also put an emphasis on how fast and how
quick and dirty could you do this and
there was an element to this of well if
you didn't have that as a stimulus how
and and you were just trying to to push
it to the max how far could one of these
things go how far had the technology
really progressed because you have to
remember it was moving very quickly in
this period with computational
aerodynamic
composite structures coming in how far
could you push this and that led us into
the thinking of what was it possible to
take this all the way back to the to the
oldest Western reference of man flying
under his own initiative that is the
story of Daedalus and Icarus which was
the the team
according to legend imprisoned on the
island of Crete back in the Late Bronze
Age who built wings of feathers and wax
and flew to flew to to freedom to
aircraft built there obviously the story
most famous because of the to the the
Sun Icarus flew in the story too close
to the Sun which melted the wax holding
the wings together and he fell to his
death as as is true even to today the
the crashes get all of the attention and
history had pretty much neglected the
idea that his father Daedalus had made
it made it safely and that story became
the the driving force behind the idea of
the Daedalus project here at MIT in the
middle 1980s this is the flight route
when we when we first started on that
project we we assumed rather naively
that it would be possible as good
engineers to go look all this up and
find the exact flight route and
literally recreate the the route the
Daedalus had flown obviously as we began
to get into that we learned a lot about
a lot about a lot of things during this
project myth classical mythology being
one of the first and of course that
there is no literal recreation possible
that myth-making is an a creative
process and builds up over time but but
applying the the navigational strategies
of the day as Mariners practiced them to
to the idea of flight it was pretty
clear that anybody who was trying to fly
from Crete and Cano sews the ruins were
actually discovered in the early part of
the century here on the north part of
Crete the nearest major landmass is up
here the island of Santorini which is 72
miles or 115 kilometers about three
times the distance of the cross-channel
flight north of the island and whatever
your eventual destination was and the
myths do disagree on the eventual
destination that that the first step
would have been to get off to the island
to get to that to to Santorini and so
that became the the flight route that we
undertook so we began looking into this
there it was a research program not only
in aeronautics as I mentioned but in
many other areas the meteorology was an
important one as we began to look into
the to the the weather in the region
obviously Paul talked a little about the
difficulties that Brian faced both in
terms of the physiology and the
meteorology we began to address those
right off the bat the existing weather
database didn't have the resolution down
in the low wind conditions that we
needed so one of the first steps was to
deploy a series of small automated
weather stations there for a year or so
before the flight as we looked for an
envelope of of weather conditions calm
wind for four four to six hours and low
temperatures temperatures were very
important because of the engine an
engine research program was undertaken
down at at Yale University
this is dr. Ethan Adele who was the
project's lead physiologist in a program
that first attempted to sort of quantify
what human performance really was so
that we could use it as engineers input
it into the aircraft sizing and and
optimization models in addition to the
physiology probably the single most
important technical advance was
numerical aerodynamics computational
aerodynamics and as practiced by by Mark
Drella
I think those of you who attended the
the symposium here it's really striking
one of the real things that came out of
this program Mark's codes now of course
that may have been a criteria for
getting invited to this symposium but I
think that I think that every single
speaker there on whichever coast or
continent is using a version of the ISIS
or MCS or X rotor codes that that mark
developed and that were first
implemented here in the in the Daedalus
project which provided the the
aerodynamic designs on the on all of the
flight surfaces propeller wing tails
everything another big part of this was
the structures to get the kind of
performance we were needing we really
had to maintain large area of laminar
flow that was partly computationally
done through Mark's codes but then we
had to implement that had to be the
structures had to be built that were
capable of sustaining that laminar
floo and numerically controlled foam
cutter was designed and built and used
to precisely cut out the all of the
different airfoil shapes that went into
to covering the leading edge you can
kind of look at the Daedalus and see
that the pink areas are the areas of
laminar flow
obviously the foam isn't very very
strong and you have to have a backbone
to that which was the job of Juan Cruz
who is now down at NASA Langley as their
composites expert but this was a
composite aircraft with one with one
wire bracing and this is a picture of
the of the full wing being proof loaded
in a test out at out at the the Lincoln
labs hangar I wanted to recognize the
critical role played by Jack Kerouac in
all of these projects because jack has
been the project's advisor and sponsor
in this every time we started one of
these projects one of the well once we
got past the initial brainstorming the
first thing we had to do is go into Jack
and ask for some money and in weather it
was in his office here is department
chair for chrysalis or when he was at
monarch we had to go down to the nath he
was a NASA associate administrator we
had to go down to NASA and then when he
was back for Daedalus he had moved up to
the dean's office and Jack has been a
critical supporter of this throughout
the whole history and none of this would
have happened I think without his
without his support we got the support
from unusual places one of the ones was
the main sponsor for the prototype of
the Daedalus was anheuser-busch and the
aircraft was named by them the Michelob
light eagle and obviously their target
market was the college crowd here's tom
clancy modeling for modeling for a for
a-- and Iser busch ad i think in this
one and that's the aircraft flying in in
January of 1987 out over Rogers dry lake
in California it was flown on for a
series of five record flights by Louis
Macallan and and Glenn Tremmel including
records over straight-line and closed
course records it broke the albatrosses
record with a 37 mile flight and then
the light eagle win
and served as a testbed it was heavily
instrumented you can see the different
instrumentation that was put on it it
became a real flight research aircraft
collecting the the quantitative data
that was needed both for the Daedalus
airplane itself for subsequent human
powered airplanes and also for some of
the high-altitude things that that Paul
alluded to the very lightweight very
flexible structures that that you need
in solar-powered aircraft for example
this was a testbed NASA sponsored part
of this part of the research program and
there was a lot of instrumentation that
went on the airplane of course all of
you associated with the project know
that the title of this picture is I
don't understand it worked back in
Cambridge by the time the the light
eagle had completed its programme we
moved into the into the Daedalus phase
itself and we began the construction of
two very refined versions of the light
eagle which were the actual Daedalus
planes and at this point we began to
transition to yet another generation of
students the the UROP program the
undergraduate research opportunities
program played a big role in this this
is as guppy here who served as the chief
engineer on the on the Daedalus planes
instructing Tom Clancy and some fine
point of how these aircraft are built
this is one with two other urops here
and as in a composite test programme as
we began every every piece of the
structure in these in the Daedalus
planes underwent proof load testing and
then the numbers were fed back into the
into the final designs and most of the
construction was done done by the urops
this this was at times a controversial
strategy there were some members of the
department who grumbled that the project
was using the using the Yurok program
for slave labour and it was it was never
clear to me where they got that
impression but anyway and we did work
hard to employ everybody in the program
the pilots even when they couldn't help
build we put them to work here they are
sewing patches onto the the team jackets
the night before the rollout this was
the the Daedalus plane as as finished in
early well I guess late 1987 the
was in in October we always remember
that because it was the day of the great
1987 stock market crash and much to the
dismay of the people from United
Technologies because there was no
mention of the Dedalus rollout because
of the large crash there were other
crashes later in the program this was
this was one that occurred in January I
guess actually early February of 1988
this was about 21 days prior to the
shipment to to Greece we had a Greek
c-130 scheduled to come and pick the
airplane up and we had four minutes of
flight time and then we and then we had
the airplane crash we lost the plane the
first plane in in I guess that was
February of 1988 fortunately we had been
working on a backup and we brought the
the wreckage of the first plane back the
rush the completion of the second
airplane forward and by early March of
88 we had the second plane flying and
the the cause of the accident was
essentially a typical not uncommon in in
in engineering projects it's a failure
to communicate among two parts of the
engineering team and the design team and
the fundamental problem was that the
aircraft which had depended on its
dihedral for for roll yaw coupling for
for lateral control the the bracing wire
which really controls that dihedral
angle was cut too short and that wasn't
caught in the manufacturing or checkout
process and the aircraft didn't have
adequate control once we had had traced
that problem and analyzed it was very
easy to fix and the second aircraft flew
beautifully made us an abbreviated
series of test flights and then was
packed up in a in a c-130 and and sent
over two degrees once in Greece there
was a lot going on there obviously the
Aegean is a region noted for its
changeable weather and the aircraft had
to be protected so the urops went to
work again and we built a hangar we had
we had purchased a prefabricated hangar
and taken it over
that team went over a few days ahead of
time we had secured a small fleet of
inflatable
boats which we had been loaned to us by
several organizations over there the
engines had been had been provided here
in the United States and so we had we
converted the the UROP team from
builders into boat teams the first
couple of drills here were pretty wild
with people overboard and radios that
went in the water and all of that that
went into making the the flight but we
had plenty of time to sort this out
because as the meteorology got worked
through in the sious teague Solari here
the director of flight operations on the
program we we didn't get very many
opportunities we knew that we wouldn't
have very many that we had five or six a
year was the prediction and we were up
against a weather cutoff because it
would get too hot in the summer we
simply didn't have the capability to
keep flying into the summer because of
the high temperatures that we would
encounter in the region we did have
several false alarms or where we got up
and put the went through the whole
flight deployment drill had the pilot
sealed up in the cockpit there sitting
on the on the runway ready to go this is
this is Mark and I guess that I think
that's Frank Scotia and the in the
cockpit on on this ready to go and then
at the very last minute making the call
of the world the conditions were not
what we wanted all along the route and
and scrubbing the flight and putting the
whole thing thing back in there there
was a lot of waiting the plane was ready
and and there was a lot of waiting for
which was which is a very anxious period
it's a beautiful area there but it was
it was hard to relax and enjoy it
waiting for this there was a lot of
other dynamics going on I love this
picture because it kind of captures all
of the players we were dealing with in
here the the military got involved
because of course we were operating off
a Greek military base that's pretty
obvious the church was a little less
obvious the church was involved because
the issue came up of gee what if the
weather was perfect on Easter Sunday and
there was great debate within the team
about how to handle that we finally went
to the archbishop and and briefed him on
the project and asked what his guidance
was he he said go for it he said if the
weather is good you guys go for it
gasoline turned out to be another factor
that you wouldn't have thought would be
a limit in a human-powered aircraft
obviously the airplane didn't need it
but all the boats did and this was the
the supplies that were needed for one
day of flying or the boats the boat
support for day of flight operations
there the the people who kept the
busiest I think were the pilots we had a
team of five of them on rotation this
was because we had had figured that this
was going to be right at the limit of of
what any human physiology was capable of
and we had recruited and trained five
world-class athletes who were in a in a
rotation much like baseball pitchers
where they were on for two days and then
you know in a rotation cycle off for for
six or eight days depending on how many
were healthy obviously injuries for
another big another big part of this so
the the training regime was very
important they were riding hundreds of
miles each day in the to train they
obviously came into the project as
excellent athletes they were all Olympic
level cyclists when they joined the
project and in the course of the project
they were all trained to be highly
skilled pilots a lot of that was in
high-performance sailplanes they started
in and obviously lower training
sailplanes and quickly moved into
high-performance sailplanes a lot of the
training took place on a simulator which
combined a visual alpha window display
with an ergometer your power was
actually being measured here as you
pedaled and that power reading was fed
into the into the simulation and
displayed so you had the full flight
controls as well as the the power going
into the simulation and then once all of
that was completed you would fly the
light eagle the light eagle had become
the training airplane and once you had
gone through this regime you flew the
eagle and one of the requirements was
you had to get through a minimum of two
hours of a two hour long flight a number
of flights in the eagle including one at
least two hours long before you could
get into into the into the Daedalus and
once you had gone through all of that
you were checked out to fly the Daedalus
this is the this is
one pilots food ration for one day and
it's it's pretty amazing the the
nutritionists from shaklee corporation
who were a sponsor at this time helped
go over and sort of rewrote the whole
diet of the of the kitchen in the in the
place we were staying and the pilots the
pilots had this at first all the rest of
the team was pretty envious of this
because this looked pretty good but the
then it turned out as the day wore on
and they realized that these guys had to
eat the same thing every day it became a
little less attractive the the rest of
the team got to got to vary their their
meal a little bit more the in-flight
meal service was provided by ethan Nadel
yeah this is ethan all as we called it
it was a very high-performance drink
which had been optimized to be right at
the limits of what a human could
tolerate in the system in terms of of
replenishing the the glycogen in that
you needed to keep your keep your your
muscles functioning and Ethan had had
moved into this and had developed this
drink had had debugged it on the pilots
through various versions and the there's
actually a toned-down version consumer
version I think that Shaklee is still is
still marketing there were what was it
six quarts of that on the on the
airplane or something like that six
litres four litres after a period of
what seemed like interminable waiting
was probably more like three weeks now
in retrospect but we finally did get a
day where things begin to really line up
across the the whole Aegean and the the
crew was brought out that I guess the
2:00 a.m. wake-up and the Assembly of
the aircraft it began at about 4:00 in
the morning and the plane was put
together there on the runway a lot of
white knuckles in the boats and watching
as we got ready and then Kanellis was
given the go-ahead and and took off I
mentioned that Kanellis was the pilot by
by luck of the draw here that that his
number was came up on the day that the
the weather conditions were good and so
shortly after 7:00 a.m. can almost took
off from this runway and
and went over the edge of this of this
embankment here and headed out and the
airplane which had looked so huge when
we were up close to it suddenly looked
completely different in terms of
something it was tiny has as he set out
on this on this flight you can see in
the background there the big ferries
that go every night to and from from
Athens and you can see the inflatables
that are accompanying it in case the
aircraft had to had to ditch we were
prepared to take the airplane under tow
we had tried to absorb all of the
lessons from the Albatross project and
albatrosses strategy for example was
that I had to take a fishing line and
try to hook a ring on the aircraft
Daedalus had I had a refine system that
had the tow line in the airplanes on the
event that Kanellis wanted to be taken
under tow he would have dropped the line
and and the the boat underneath taken it
up and towed it navigation was done from
a command boat following behind the the
aircraft there this is a nice shot
looking up you can see the see the
carbon structure there and the region of
laminar flow on the top it really is
laminar back to about 60% pretty much
you can see where the where the foam
foam goes to on the on the top surface
the bottom is almost all laminar it
didn't need the the foam and you get
another view this is looking straight
down on the aircraft and again a good
view of the laminar flow we had escorts
provided by the the Greek Navy and the
Greek Coast Guard they were there their
primary role was for in case we needed
any emergency medical rescue that was
provided by the by the boats and they
also helped keep the keep the route
clear from other from other boats that
would have gotten in the way this is a
great picture gives you a sense of the
speed at which Kanellis was was flying
and also the crosswinds that he was
managing you can see the the crab in
there the boats obviously and the wakes
are marking the the direct flight route
to Santorini there and and this picture
gives you a good sense of the smooth
surface of the upper upper part
the wing this is a another good example
of the doing more with less that Paul
was just talking about where the the
speedboat there has what is that is that
a 120 horse motor on the 130 horse motor
on the on the back of that speedboat
there the Daedalus has a quarter
horsepower motor in it and they're going
the same speed and it's all it's all due
to the refinement of the technology and
the application of technology to to to
energy efficiency here the the flight
had been projected to take as long as
six hours we train for six hours but the
conditions were good and and and
Kanellis was just fantastic his heart
rate when he started was about a hundred
and fifty six and declined throughout
the flight by the time we were inside of
santorini his heart rate was down to 126
which still his absence just boggles my
mind how cool he was and throughout all
of this we had actually by this time
most of the team had deployed to the
landing site and was was was watching
marking the the site there with with
smoke and then Kanellis had the choice
of going straight in onto the beach a
lot has been made of the fact that the
aircraft broke up we were I'm here to
say we were maneuvering this thing to
try to get it back in one piece can also
easily could have gone straight in onto
the beach if the objective was to was
just to get it onto the onto the beach
but we really wanted to try to maneuver
the airplane in and land it we had all
seen that Society of Brian Allen
slipping it in there under the beach in
France and that was pretty much the
maneuver we were working on here so
Kanellis came in at fairly high speed
turns in parallel to the beach and tries
to to slip it in parallel here you can
see the the beginning of the fail you
can actually see the buckling right
there in the in the carbon tail boom as
the as a gust of wind thermally induced
coming off this black sand catches this
torques the tail tail fails right there
the tail boom fails the wires are the
cables that control the elevator are
outside at that point says this torques
that puts a full command on the on the
horizontal stabbed there
/ stresses the way it fails out and
right near a transport joint on the on
the right hand side and the aircraft
drops into the into the into the water
they are just off off the shore we had a
lot of people help us take it apart at
this point that was the problem there if
you go to Santorini I'm sure there's
still pink pink foam souvenirs in some
of the shops there and and there's
Kanellis after the after the flight
whoo-hoo no kidding could have gone on
for for quite a while on this flight
and that's the team there on the on the
beach many of whom are here today could
I get everybody who is on the team to
stand up at this point everybody who
worked on the project could you stand
many of the people I think haven't seen
each other in 10 years after this and I
really do thank ed Crawley for pulling
this whole thing together
well the devilís project always you know
it was done for education it was done
for research it was a marvelous project
it could never answer the question of so
what and when people asked it in the
lectures but but one of the interesting
things about science is that it really
when you really are doing research is
that that you never know where the the
next problem is going to come from in it
and in Daedalus for me anyway it came
from a very unexpected source in in the
mid-80s there were two things that
emerged that kind of shifted the
paradigm from nuclear holocaust being
the sort of you know big picture issue
that that that kind of hung over all of
us and those two issues were the
emergence of AIDS the break out of that
into the general population and the
depletion of stratospheric ozone in
terms of issues that when they first
began to appear no one was quite sure
how bad this was going to be and that
clearly had the potential to to to
eliminate life as as we knew it if in a
worst-case scenario the the ozone hole
obviously appeared over Antarctica in
the in the early 80s and in the mid 80s
a lot of attention was directed towards
figuring out exactly what it was the
primary tools for doing that were large
stratospheric balloons and the an
aircraft called the ER to which NASA
operates it's a version of the military
spy plane and these worked okay for
figuring out the for the causes of the
Antarctic ozone hole and and providing
the conclusive links between
chlorofluorocarbons and the and the
catalytic cycles that destroyed the
ozone but it was also clear that the
scientists to answer the question of is
this going to spread to other places on
the planet is this going to happen in
the northern hemisphere is it going to
happen over the middle latitudes that
you needed to go out and take
measurements at higher altitudes and in
more places around the planet and a
couple of us from from the Daedalus
project linked up with a group down at
Harvard in the atmospheric research
project there and began construction of
a series of aircraft that would attempt
to apply the aerodynamics and the
structures and some of the project
management philosophies that came out of
Daedalus and applied them to a series of
small very customized robotic aircraft
that could be used for atmospheric
science high altitude research initially
in the ozone area and we built an
aircraft just called Perseus about 60 62
feet in in wingspan developed the
controls technology for that and made a
series of flights this is really to give
you a sense of scale of the of the
Perseus this particular aircraft has
carried about a 220 pound payload to an
altitude of about 50,000 feet and and
both the solar plane and the the Perseus
aircraft are are working together our
joint participants in a NASA program
that's developing the technology for
future operational aircraft and we've
also applied that to it to a larger
aircraft that's really designed
specifically around the needs of the
scientists called Theseus and that's the
larger twin-engine aircraft in the back
and we have built this is a hundred and
forty foot wingspan aircraft that
carries between 750 and and 1,500 pounds
of of instruments on board and the
eventually to altitudes of 85,000 feet
or so for four fairly long Endurance's
this is an airplane that's in in
development and it's a direct outgrowth
of the Daedalus technologies I wanted to
what to close here and and if I had the
time if I have the time here which I
think I do Cory are you can you cue up
the short video before as you put that
in I just wanted to close with a few
thoughts here on yeah on this this
picture which is the layered structure
of the of the atmosphere here which is
which is is really a neat picture
showing the whole the whole path here
and I think the the lessons that Paul
has been talking about certainly the
lessons that we have drawn from Daedalus
support very much the idea that the the
atmosphere is although it looks very
large it looks like it's a
and NSYNC for many purposes it really
isn't if you look at this picture above
that line is space a very hostile
environment below that line is is earth
and everything on it that we we know and
hold dear and that atmosphere is a very
thin line that separates those those two
from each other it's it's amazingly
undersampled there's still a lot to be
done and there to the future generations
of students who are coming along
hopefully some of whom are in the room
attending this lecture today there is
still a lot to be done and these types
of programs that Paul and I have talked
about here are great ways to to get into
it it's like - if you can cue up this
this video this is a piece that Brian
Sullivan edited together of the of the
flight
you
okay thank you very very much
well I think we have a chance to
entertain a few few questions from the
audience and then we'll wrap up why
don't Kanellis why don't you come down
here and tell us that and then we'll
then we'll close on that
first you first thank you for the
opportunity give me the talk sorry for
my bad english about the the last moment
you know there when I was pedaling in
towards to Santorini was the tailwind so
no problem no big problems and over
there as John said because of the high
speed we had they decide to make me do a
turn so we did the turn but during the
turn we face the wind and the wind
approaching the land was too hard so the
plane was going up and down like you
have seen there this plane was not
designed to do all those things so it
resisted too much and one moment I felt
no it was not my feeling was real the
plane was flying but staying in the same
place because they wind had the speed of
the plane so it was very tough and then
he took a bank you know and it was not
possible to make it return back so he
did once he did twice and then broken
the the tail so it was but it was closed
but I think this this end because was
not so easy and smooth like the other
make a very you know put fear to someone
else who wants to do the same that is
not so easy
well with that I think we'll will
conclude this year's Gardner lecture
thank you very much for coming
[Applause]